[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir je m'appelle camille c'est la
première fois que je participe à un
groupe de soutien comme celui ci donc ça
fait quatre ans maintenant que j'ai
arrêté le rebond j'ai encore des
rechutes 1 je fais pas la maline alors
comme il paraît qu'une image vaut mieux
que de longs discours je vous ai mis une
une image justement au voilà alors je
sais pas si vous la reconnaissez sa part
oui un peut-être d'autres ne connaissent
pas c'était le premier jeu sur
ordinateur et la règle était assez
compliqué 1 il s'agissait de renvoyer la
balle
voilà c'est la règle plus vous renvoyer
la balle plus vous marquez des points
quand vous raté la balle vous raté les
points quoi c'est ça voilà en tout cas
c'était tout pour moi merci beaucoup
c'est bon je vais vous raconter
l'histoire longue alors et vous
expliquer pourquoi j'ai choisi cette
image cette image en fait qui représente
une boîte une boîte noire et cette image
c'est un petit peu la métaphore de ma
vie ça a été ma vie pendant longtemps
jusqu'en 2015
je n'ai en lorraine il ya quelques
années à tous là les boules
non mais si ceux qui connaissent tous le
camp même les boules et avant mais mes
deux ans à 21 mois exactement je vis
d'eux drame le premier c'est que je n'ai
dans une hémorragie de la délivrance
alors pour ceux qui ne savent pas ce que
c'est c'est quand on fait le placent la
tare est accroché en fait il ne vient
pas avec le bébé et ça provoque une
hémorragie la mer ce peut se vider de
son sang en quelques minutes
heureusement ma mère est sauvé mais moi
j'en garde un stress inconscient très
fort et puis une culpabilité d'avoir
peut-être failli tuer ma mère et quand
j'ai 21 moi je vis avec mes parents et
mes deux frères en abitibi clay et
et sans crier gare la mort va frapper
puisque mon frère benjamin décède il a 9
ans et en quelques minutes on se
retrouve comme les statuts de pompéi si
vous voyez comme ça en cendres ça nous
fout complètement
il ya un avant et un après on ne
comprend pas moi je ne comprends pas en
tout cas j'ai 21 mois je perds mon frère
mais je perds aussi toute la famille en
fait tout le monde implose on ne parle
pas on n'explique pas et pendant de
nombreuses années jusqu'à aujourd'hui en
fait on ne dit pas son nom on n'en parle
pas il prend toute la place mais on n'en
parle pas et moi à ce moment là je pense
que je prends une décision inconsciente
je décide de devenir de tout faire pour
échapper à cette boîte en fait qui fait
très peur quand même un qui peut nous
enfermer et de devenir la plus vivante
la plus la plus rebondissante possible
donc je ne vais poser aucun problème je
vais grandir comme ça jusqu'au jour où
on quitte la lorraine quand j'ai à peu
près 10 ans et demi on part à l'île de
la réunion
là je m'adapte une hyper adapte aux
tropiques je fais beaucoup de théâtre
j'en fais dix heures par semaine j'ai
écrit des sketches jeu je monte des
projets je pars à madagascar bon bref et
puis ensuite j'ai décidé de prendre un
petit peu de large par rapport à mes
parents et je veux venir à paris et mes
parents me disent ok mais si tu veux à
la part il faut faire quelque chose qui
n'existe pas à la réunion j'ai dit
d'accord
donc je fais une hypokhâgne alors une
hypokhâgne au lycée janson de sailly
dans le xvième
je n'avais pas bien conscience de ce que
c'était avec une option latin manger
vite compris 10 heures de latin par
semaine je lisais plaute couramment dans
le texte c'était incroyable claude qui
lançait deux molières d'ailleurs la
marmite de plaute faut le savoir bon non
mais c'est important toujours de prendre
un petit pot de cultures bon et puis bon
bah moi je bonnan malange c'est pas
brillant je vais en fin d'année comme je
peux et je me dis ouf je vais pouvoir
bifurquer faire ce que je veux du
théâtre et non la gema prof d'anglais
qui dit camille caminaïres vient d'avoir
le conseil de classe
merci qui grâce à qui vous passez en
khâgne parce que c'était pas gagné 1 ça
s'est joué à ça c'est moi qui ai poussé
un alors vers liquide
dont je fais la cagne et là je me
retrouve avec les hispanophones de paris
c'est très sympa parce qu'ils ont une
capacité à beaucoup travailler en étant
très très très très stressant ce picasso
tistes chrono en étant extrêmement
brillant donc à beaucoup de tapage
beaucoup de pas et la boue
oui c'est très cliché mais je vous
assure que c'est vrai et bien sûr à la
fin d'année je n'ai pas le concours
voilà alors qu'amy vous n'avez pas eu le
concours ntone cesca milano peau dida
voilà tout à fait
oui c'est bien nelson monfort simon
reconnaît quand même
donc j'arrive en licence d'anglais à
nanterre voilà toujours leurs gonds je
rebondis à l'université de paris-x
nanterre entre le rer et mon ampli
d'anglais j'ai déjà dit tracts j'ai
signé quatre pétition j'ai adhéré à huit
syndicats la grande époque de paris-x
nanterre puis là je me pose pas trop de
questions en fait j'ai pas analysé
réellement jusque là ce qui s'est passé
on en 97 et à nouveau la mort va frapper
je suis en couple avec mon compagnon il
a une soeur unique qui est en train de
mourir d'une leucémie en a 20 ans et ça
fait plusieurs années qu'elle se bat
contre cette maladie depuis ses 13 ans
rechute rémission rechute rémission
stéphane mon ami lui a donné sa moelle
osseuse il a fait une greffe de moelle
mais ça n'a pas suffit donc sa mère nous
appelle novembre 97 pour nous dire dans
trois semaines c'est fini alors là mon
corps fait oh la la c'est à dire que
voilà lui si c'était pour le relevage et
donc non c'est rien c'est pour moi
et donc est donc et donc oui mon corps
donc me lâche et j'aime ce rebond
intérieur d'aller voir une
psychothérapeute pour lui dire je crois
que j'ai envie de mourir parce que rien
n'a de sens en fait je ne comprends pas
à l'idée qu'elle est le projet et et
prend trois mois elle m'aide à résoudre
mon envie de mourir elle mais elle me
remet sur les rails et je commence à
faire le travail à comprendre que cette
mort d'enfants parce qu'elle est petite
elle a 20 ans et tout petit me ramène à
la mort non résolus de mon frère et je
commence à travailler sur la famille
alors je travaille pendant 22 ans
jusqu'à aujourd'hui psychogénéalogie
gulftown psychanalyse pendant sept ans
marathon de thérapie reeber je passe
dans les matelas respiration automatique
pour oxygéner toutes les parties du
corps bien sûr on n'y pense pas assez
dépollution des mémoires cellulaires
lavage du côlon reiki enfin bref
non mais vraiment way inamicale et je
les fais qui après je me forme en tant
qu'art thérapeute et coach est donc en
parallèle de cette thérapie je continue
je reprends mon mouvement de survie
comme je sais bien faire et puis
j'arrive en maîtrise l'anglais bon voilà
je fais un mémoire sur les femmes
hollywoodienne c'est dans les films
américains sur la guerre du vietnam
pourquoi pas tu aurais tu veux dire un
bon et puis en parallèle je fais plein
de petits boulots pour gagner ma vie
alors accrochez vous bien je vous en dis
que quelques-uns je deviens place au
parc des princes oui c'est vrai enfin je
monte les marches comme ça du parc
et puis j'arrive avec ma petite banane
jeudi pour la place s'il vous plaît pour
nom très bien placé donc je redescends
toutes mes petites marques et puis je
fais le match psg om
voilà et tout en haut comme ça du parc
je vois comme ça les fumées roses un
cauchemar
un cauchemar je deviens surveillants de
salle au musée du louvre dans le train
ne touchez pas un yes to je compte dix
ans de mérite voilà je devient
animatrice à toute sorte de fête pour
enfants
les arbres de noël les coupes de cheveux
les bar mitzvah barre me farama meta
dans la joie tu reçois tu reçois la
torah je suis animatrice 6 merci j'ai un
petit castelet comme ça j'ai des
marionnettes j'ai mon petit combo avec
moins de s'appeler je le branche même je
me mets ou dans le savons très bien ce
statut musicale pc the women n'ont guère
bougé
voilà je suis également animatrice de
centre de loisirs formatrice bafa
directrice de centre de loisirs s'il
vous plaît que jean-louis nathalie ouais
il est 4 heures du matin on est debout
depuis 6 heures on va faire une réunion
d'une heure après on va pouvoir c'est
vraiment bien se reposer nous 20 bonnes
minutes 1 donc on est là voilà je suis
également je découvre alors je vous en
passe un je découvre la formation en
2004 dans l'entreprise dont je suis
formatrice en prise de parole ancrage
articulations gestuelle etc
j'éprouve de plaidoiries à l'école du
barreau non votre honneur non effets de
manche
mon client gérard michel
je vous jure que j'ai vécu ça un avocat
commis d'office qui arrivé comme ça avec
tous les dossiers comme quand vous avez
comme vous appeler michel incroyable
bref et puis et puis et puis je suis et
puis en parallèle je deviens quand même
comédienne 1 c'était quand même
information
alors là je mens 3 spectacle seul en
scène j'ai écrit deux bouquins et je
participe à des pièces comme un drôle de
paire avec michel leeb philippe uchan au
théâtre montparnasse
après le tombeur j'étais fabienne
fabienne alors j'avais un petit accent
du nord hayange gaudreault je ne sais
pas bien j'étais un petit peu la
taulière quoi ce n'est entré chez les
jeunes hôtes et les entrées les sorties
de toutes les femmes y avait un ballet
de mai presse était improbable
voilà ensuite judas adopte un veuf je
suis la conac australienne libertines
je vais tout partager je comprends pas
pourquoi ils les limites de la peau
c'est vrai pourquoi on tue et sceller la
théorie des cordes ont fait ça c'est les
électrons c'est la vibration
voilà je suis aussi olga jakobson dans
la gare du royal place car j'avais
appris une phrase à nonant le pin s'est
amusé voilà bref je vous en passe aussi
et j'arrive en 2015 hélas 2015 on en a
parlé tout à l'heure il ya une année
difficile à paris on est on revient de
tournée il ya une comédienne qui a un
petit rôle elle a pas beaucoup de la
lada du temps on va dire pour être sûr
seront sûres sont sur son téléphone elle
nous dit on est on est sur lequel la
gare elle nous dit il ya une tuerie qui
vient d'avoir lieu chez charlie hebdo
comment quelle est l'idée les mots ne
vont pas ensemble et donc elles nous
disent ici et nous on devait aller chez
michel drucker pour enregistrer
l'émission de vivement dimanche au
canapé rouge et on arrivait michel
rigueur avait perdu beaucoup de ses amis
ce jour là donc il était livide personne
ne comprenait rien on était abattus
pardon sans jugement et dans l'année qui
a suivi
il s'est passé également bataclan il
s'est passé qui perd cacher il s'est
passé le carillon il s'est passé
beaucoup de choses et moi à ce moment-là
mon corps à hrw
oh je leur ferais pas mais je pourrais
sans problème ce juste un choix c'est
complètement voilà et donc est donc que
2015 voilà à mon corps me lâche à
nouveau parce que toute la journée je
forme je coach contre temps je suis
devenu coach je me suis certifié au
coaching et tous les soirs je suis sur
scène cette fois par semaine on a fait
une tournée de plus de 200 dates toute
la france la suisse découpe des petits
bouts que je ne connaissais pas le
luxembourg l'océan indien enfin bref on
a tout fait et et moi je suis donc au
théâtre et pendant bataclan en fait
quand ça arrive par l amène comédienne
avec son téléphone elle est vraiment un
petit rôle elle nous dit il ya une
tuerie en ce moment au bataclan
j'écoute est évidemment c'est l'horreur
c'est absolument l'horreur genre est ici
mais c'est un énorme énorme traumatisme
pour moi je on traverse paris ventre à
terre je prends mes deux chiennes
j'avais machine avec mon horloge et puis
je
j'arrive dans mon appartement le lundi
suivant je suis en train de former dans
la grande arche de la défense des cadres
dynamiques et pour y aller je prends un
métro et là je vois que les gens sont
blancs peu près de cette couleur-là
blanc livide
dès qu'il ya un petit bruit genre enfin
normal dans le métro tous montés tout le
monde manque de s'évanouir
et là je me dis en fait tous à tous que
pour ça c'est à dire que peut-être là je
pars dans petits morceaux et à quoi bon
finalement et je me dis que finalement
depuis toutes ces années
moi qui pensait échapper à la boîte je
n'ai fait que rebondir dans la boîte et
que ma zone de confort est devenu ce
ballon crevé qui est un fauteuil
d'ailleurs et que si je veux vraiment
sortir la boîte il va falloir fabriquer
une autre boîte
donc je prends conscience de ça et je
change tout j'arrête la viande jarrets
de l'aspartame j'arrête les tampons
envoyé peut-être pas le lien logique
mais il y en a
je change les bordures en fourrure de
mai capuche ça a l'air de rien mais
après m'être fait agresser par une
militante en allemagne elle avait raison
en plus j'étais d'accord jeudi
il faut que je me mette en cohérence
qu'est ce que je fais encore alors et
puis et puis je me forme au coaching aux
états unis avec tony robbins et je
spécialise en fait pour les personnes
qui veulent comme moi sa ligne et c'est
à dire arrêter de se dire qu'elle va
être mon prochain rebond mais plutôt de
se poser cette question
2 qu'est ce qui est bon pour moi voilà
sortir sortir du fait de prouver sans
arrêt de six paires adapté de survivre
de s'arracher je vais faire la thaïlande
deux jours je vais faire le dk plantes
ou en tongs
pourquoi pas et plutôt se dire qu'est ce
qui est bon pour moi
hop voilà j'ai mis sept cette petite
image que je trouve très jolie et donc
depuis ça va ça va bien je vous cache
pas que c'est un long travail c'est
toujours en cours je me rends compte que
j'ai plein d'autres dépendances en ce
moment je suis en train de lutter contre
celle du téléphone
c'est assez dingue de voir comment ça
peut prendre beaucoup de temps beaucoup
d'énergie beaucoup de stress mais
j'espère que mon histoire vous a parlé
que vous avez pu vous identifier je
pense qu'elle résonne et quand on arrive
à faire se poser cette question de
caisse qui est bon pour moi c'est à dire
de sortir de la compensation c'est
sortir de l' hyper adaptation retrouver
cette bienveillance dont on parlait tout
à l'heure cette confiance en soi avant
de la donner aux autres déjà prendre
conscience de la violence qu'on peut se
faire vivre des fois dans le rythme
qu'on a dans l'alimentation qu'on a dans
les fréquentations conte à la toxicité
con qu'on entretient et bien c'est
peut-être un petit pas pour l'humanité
mais c'est un très grand bond pour soi
merci
[Applaudissements]